is getting a certification and doing  Hands-On Labs really enough to land a  cloud job well no on its own a cloud  certification with some Hands-On Labs  does not guarantee your job you need to  demonstrate hard skills but how do you  compensate for this experience well by  working on Hands-On projects pick a  project that spans across more  programming languages some sort of  programming networking and some basic  Linux command knowledge in deploying the  applications in Cloud so an example  project could be something like building  an API or a web application it will  require you to develop the code for your  application then it would have to pick  the infrastructure to deploy that  application in the cloud and then pick  some sort of storage and database to  interact with that and in that process  you would basically end up learning how  the internet works the networking HTTP  TCP SSL and more and that prepares you  for a cloud job